Disney Channel might seem all sunshine
and rainbows on screen but when the
cameras stop rolling it's far from it
I'm gonna be getting into one of the
most long-standing media covered feuds
in all of Disney history the Realty
between the Raven Simone and the Cheetah
Girls and the shocking friendship that
never was on Hannah Montana one of the
most iconic media covered feuds in all
of Disney history is the one between
Hilary Duff and Lindsay Lohan they are
literally Disney royalty at this point
these two were at Major high points in
their careers at the same time and
literally never got along why a Boy
Aaron Carter specifically they both
dated him and it caused a major break in
their already fragile friendship I
invited Hilary Duff to be here with me
tonight so come on out Hillary it also
didn't help that the media were truly
pitting these two girls against each
other causing an uncomfortable pick a
side Vibe between their fan base glad
we're clearing things up I agree Lindsay
our whole food is so yesterday so
yesterday Zendaya and Bella Thorne were
the stars of the show Shake it up before
it got canceled after season three rumor
has it the show was doing great but it
was due to Zendaya and Bella Thorne's
relationship that ultimately caused it
to crumble according to the media the
two stars would often fight for the
spotlight all the time making the show
incredibly difficult for everyone else
on set yikes Ashley Tisdale and Lucas
grabiel really stole the show as the
iconic brother and sister duo in High
School Musical
although their on-screen chemistry was
completely unmatched it was a totally
different story in real life they ended
up talking about it over a decade later
saying that not only did they not get
along on set but they absolutely hated
working with one another and I do become
a lot like the character and I think he
thought I was really like Sharpay again
Gotta Give it to their acting skills
because I really never would have known
otherwise Miley Cyrus and Emily Osment
played on-screen best friends Miley and
Lily in Hannah Montana honestly this one
caught me off guard apparently they were
never really friends on set in Miley's
2009 autobiography miles to go Miley
wrote there were times when I didn't
think we could ever be friends we just
couldn't figure out how to get along I
guess these two really could act back
then because I would have been none the
wiser Selena Gomez and Miley Cyrus are
another pair of Disney Royals who got
into a little Rift over a boy this boy
being Nick Jonas is anyone getting
flashbacks to Miley's seventh things era
Miley dated Nick from 2006 to 2008 and
when they broke up Nick b-lined it right
for Selena there was a lot of drama
after that on Twitter and even in live
performances with Miley performing Fu
holding a cardboard cutout of Selena
Gomez's head from what I've gathered now
is that the two are good friends in the
present day and have since well gotten
over the Jonas Brother The Cheetah Girls
are a musical group that consists of
Raven Simone Adrian Balon Sabrina Bryan
and Kylie Williams
oh that's right they made movies
released records and did live shows
together all over the world but it was
clear from the beginning that Raven was
always the front woman and star
apparently according to Raven there was
a lot of cat fights and territorial
issues I have the urge to make a cheetah
joke right now but you guys get the gist
there was talk about a Cheetah Girls
reunion but it really came down to none
of the girls wanting to talk to Adrian
calm down take a pill for a second and
say
I'm pissed at you but let's talk about
it in 2011 during Zendaya's Shake It Up
years there was a little issue between
Demi Lovato and Zendaya that has since
been resolved basically there was a joke
on the show about eating disorders which
yeah was so not the vibe and Demi Lovato
spoke out against it she lashed out at
both Disney and Zendaya for the joke as
she's never been shy about sharing her
own personal struggles I personally am
with Demi on this and clearly so was
Zendaya as the issue was resolved not
too long after and the two to this day
remain good friends Selena Gomez and
Jake T Austin play brother and sister on
the show Wizards of Waverly Place in
true sibling fashion the two got into a
major argument via Twitter which caused
for a pretty uncomfy filming experience
for the rest of the show's run Jake gave
Selena a hard time for her role in
Spring Breakers which obviously didn't
go well and caused some issues between
them on set again in true sibling
fashion the two have since moved on from
the issue and have remained friends ever
since I gotta give props to a lot of
these actors because I truly never would
have known that some of them didn't get
along on set it's crazy how dating the
wrong boy or saying the wrong thing on
Twitter can cause year-long Rifts
between people what Disney Feud do you
think should have been included on this
list let us know in the comments